welcome to meet the Germans I'm kake
news on the German language can be so
hilarious I'm going to share with you at
some of my favorite German idioms and
I've invited a native German speaker
Mischa a committee to help explain how
to use them thanks for being here it is
glad to be here Kate so because are you
afraid of spiders not really afraid but
let's say I'm not fond of them either
I totally understand so in Germany I
hear the phrase do spins all the time I
just need to translate that as you
spider even though of course in English
we wouldn't use spider as a verb what
does that mean well it means you're
crazy
Oh so if someone says that about you you
better watch out oh I would be concerned
if someone said that about me but I also
hear people saying that about themselves
when they say ich bin
well that means people are really
befuddled about something and that's how
they want to express their
thoughtfulness so I can say ich bin it
but there's plastic spiders moving all
biomes and I've got a nice big hot pot
of porridge right here
you know I literally grew up eating this
stuff except in the u.s. we even call it
oatmeal and not porridge but you know
this is really taking me back
do you like porridge not always but
especially in the winter and it could be
pretty yummy I think yeah I think so -
yeah but Germans they don't only eat
their porridge right no we also have an
expression linden - but I have one
Brayden which means literally to talk
around the hot porridge to talk around
the hot well okay I guess in English we
would probably say to breathe around the
bush right yeah right okay so I've got a
pot of something hot and yummy here in
the meet the German studio but we're not
going to talk about what's inside right
no not going to happen
so mission in Germany I always find so
many flies inside because the Germans
love airing out their rooms and because
so few people have screens around here
but have you ever killed two flies at
once not really but we have an
expression spice leading with ionic
lattice login' which means to kill two
flies with one swatter she flies Oh
English we would say to kill two birds
with one stone you know to do two things
that was right but I thought that it was
kind of so
morbid with the birds let's stick with
the flies deal yeah I think I see two
more so my opinion is that German
mustard is the best mustard in the world
and it goes up practically every dish
Kate Moustafa dines an ethical game you
always have to add your master my
mustard
yep oh I see you mean I always have to
add my two cents or give my opinion
right well you're right but sometimes I
just can't help it I'm not such a big
fan of mustard actually oh you should
try it it's good well maybe I love the
German idioms are so visual aren't they
they are and translating them literally
can be lots of fun thank you so much for
joining us for meet the Germans and
helping us find out more about some of
the coolest idioms in the German
language well thanks for having me if
you know more fabulous German idioms
share them with us wouldn't be sure to
come back next time for more from me
pizza
[Music]
that's a start I get you today getting
if I say so I'm not going to put it on
you I might put it on you and anyway I
used to pay my brothers a dollar to kill
them seriously yeah well a dollar was
steep I would you could sense that's me
this is put your lighter
yes to the side okay I don't know you're
the poor American family from a
different part of the United States but
they did not play porn no they don't
over yeah oh hell yeah okay I literally
did grow up and okay yeah right
so okay I've got a nice big pot of
porridge yummy I'm gonna believe it
I'm not really such a big fan of mustard
actually oh you should try it it's great
everyone loves German message well this
is really hot stuff this is a extra yeah
thank you so much for joining me
underneath the Germans and helping us
helping us out usually it helping us out
is what I say all the time - ho ho - ah
so far yeah whatever third time's the
charm is hitting rebel